a first member of my family I was able
to participate in this moving
commemorative events
United Kingdom and uh Germany on the
path of Germany and on a path
president
so einroxval the reason
by participating in the commemoration
today the end of the first world war in
London
to be with you once again
now as king
and to renew the special bond of
friendship between our two countries
this friendship meant so much to my
beloved mother the late Queen
who often spoke of the 15 official
visits she made Germany including her
five State visits
the first of those in
1965 came when our continent was still
deeply scarred by War and the trauma of
conflict
hers was the wartime generation and like
my father the queen had served in
uniform
that my parents 11-day tour of Germany
should prove to be a pivotal moment in
the reconciliation between our Nations
was therefore a matter of great personal
significance to them both
of Worcester
in Deutschland
she visited German very often and wanted
to make her contribution
that is the reason why
she has gained such a valuable part in
the hearts of Germans